what's going on people today we're about
to break down episode 22 of attack on
titan season 4 in which the rumbling
continues and annie finally escapes her
crystal after years of being forced to
listen to armin
in this video i'll be explaining all the
small details you need to know including
the reason why aaron didn't stop the
titans from rampaging and why flock is
about to go to war with the volunteers
before we get into it though i just want
to say that we are so close to reaching
400k subs so if you've been enjoying
these breakdowns then i'd really
appreciate if you smash that sub button
if you haven't
already okay so in the last episode ymir
disobeyed zeke's order to sterilize the
elding race and instead he chose to help
aaron in his plan to destroy all life
outside the island within minutes of
gaining the founder's power aaron then
sent a telepathic message to every
aldean and this new episode begins with
annie's dad's reaction to that message
as someone living in the liberio
internment zone he quickly realizes that
he's about to be trampled by the
rumbling alongside everyone else on the
marlin continent
one piece of trivia that i thought was
worth mentioning is that as far as we
know aaron's grandparents are still
alive in liberio so by flattening marley
he's also knowingly murdering his own
grandparents as well
now moving back to the island gabby and
reina were on the search to find falco
the last time we saw this character he
had just eaten porco and his pure titan
was lying there in the street for anyone
to grab
as the new holder of the draw titan his
human body would have emerged at some
point after this screenshot and when
that happened jon swooped in to take him
away reiner correctly assumed that this
is what happened since there was no way
that the scouts would have just ignored
one of the nine titans he then falls to
his knees as his body took serious
damage when the walls fell down and this
is because aaron weakened his armor
titan by removing all the hardening to
be more specific when aaron began the
rumbling he used his power to undo all
titan hardening in the world including
the armatain's armor annie's crystal and
obviously the wars themselves because of
that it meant the debris from the wall
directly hit rhino's unarmored titan
which is why he's so injured in the
first place
after they find a place to rest he makes
it pretty clear that he doesn't believe
aaron can be beaten since the founder
has ultimate control over all other
titans and all subjects of ymir despite
this gabby still has the determination
to at least try to stop the rumbling and
this scene of her tying up her hair is a
direct parallel to when aaron did the
same thing in these moments both of them
were looking in the mirror mentally
preparing themselves for the fight ahead
and if you give me a second i'm going to
quickly explain some of the other
parallels between them to start with it
was confirmed several years ago that
gabby design is based off this sketch of
female aaron which helps to explain the
visual similarity between the two in
terms of personality we've seen many
times that they each have an insane
level of willpower and similar to how
eren once believed that freedom would
come when they wiped out the titans
gabby believed that eldians in mali
would have a better life once the island
devils were all wiped out since then
both of them have gone through drastic
transformations and now their core
motivation is to protect the people they
care about this ties into the next scene
where jean acknowledges that they're the
ones who are going to benefit from aaron
destroying humanity thanks to the
rumbling they'll all be able to live
peacefully on the island without the
danger of being destroyed by mali and
historia no longer has to become a titan
shifter after she gives birth on top of
that none of them will be victims of
zeke's euthanization plan meaning that
overall aaron has done what he's done so
that they can all live long lives
that being said jon was still clearly
unsure about whether this could be
justified while armin was pretty certain
that a massacre on this scale was going
way too far
a minute later the pure titans he
created then started attacking nearby
aldian soldiers since they'd finished
eating the malian soldiers who were in
the district
now in theory these pure titans
shouldn't be rampaging like this because
as yelena and armin pointed out at least
one of the egg brothers should be able
to control them
in zeke's case he's normally able to
command the times he creates but at this
time he's got bigger things to worry
about as he was seemingly absorbed by
the source of all living matter
in aaron's case he should also be able
to control the titans as he has control
over the coordinate but his inaction can
be explained by something he said during
the declaration of war in his own words
he keeps moving forward until his
enemies are destroyed and in this new
situation his founding tyson is
literally marching forward to trample
their enemies as a result he's ignoring
all the chaos that might be happening
behind him as his singular focus right
now is to continue marching until the
job's done that's why he's not
interfered with anything that's happened
on parity since the rumbling started
with the consequence being that these
titans are just allowed to go crazy and
attack anyone who's nearby before the
scouts deal with that though there was a
brief argument surrounding what they
should do with falco feeding falco to
someone would turn that person back into
a human and jon points out that they can
use this method to bring back commander
pixis
understandably connie's choice was to
bring back his mother instead but armin
wasn't so keen on feeding falco to
anyone from his point of view killing
the warrior would only continue their
conflict with the other warriors which
is something they don't have to do in a
world where marley no longer exists
however that reasoning alone isn't
strong enough for connie to just abandon
his mother as a pure titan especially as
it's coming from the guy who was brought
back to life himself after eating one of
the warriors
during this heated debate one of the
titans smashed his face into the rooftop
giving connie an opening to quickly
kidnap falco as he flies off in the
other direction the scouts don't really
have time to go after him since they
have to kill these titans now before
their rampage moves on to more populated
areas of the island this is a genuine
possibility now that eren has destroyed
all three wars on parodies which has
left the nearby districts wide open if
the titans were going to attack for that
reason the scouts stick around to deal
with this mess instead of chasing off to
connie and a quick side note is that in
the manga this titan here looks a lot
more like saul goodman from breaking bad
anyway as the carnage continues we got a
few different shots of people inside
this fort being targeted including the
anti-marlin volunteers and a handful of
cadets these are the same cadets who
earlier in the season were certain that
there'd never be any more titan attacks
which is a statement that's now come
back to bite them in a big way
meanwhile on the ground sash's family
were being chased by nars pure titan and
after this accident kaiya ended up
getting cornered
this isn't the first time she's been
trapped in this kind of scenario only
the last time it happened sasha showed
up to save her life
that's why she calls out for sasha just
before nile lunges towards her and if he
had eaten her here then this hands down
would have been one of the most tragic
deaths in the series it's not that kaya
is an important character but her being
eaten in front of her family while
calling out for her dead sister i mean
that would have been hard to watch
luckily for her though gabby arrives at
just the right moment with her
anti-titan gun and it was mentioned a
few episodes ago that this thing can
kill pure titans with a direct hit to
the nape on her second attempt she does
manage to deal that finishing blow
putting an end to evan's longtime friend
and for a brief moment kaiya literally
sees sasha standing in front of her
besides the fact that gabby and sasha
have similar hair the reason kaia sees
this is because sasha's the one she
depends on in times of crisis and in
this scene she hadn't yet processed that
gabby stepped into that role
after this a couple of nearby aldian
soldiers arrive and they start to
suspect that gabi might not be from the
island in order to save her from being
taken away or potentially killed
everyone pretended like they were a
family while nicola used his malian
heritage as a valid excuse for why they
have this type of gun
as they're taken to safety kaia then
wonders why gabby saved her from nile
given that in the recent past she was
ranting about how earlier on the island
were devils since then her perspective
has changed a lot as i mentioned earlier
hence why she replies by saying that the
real devil was her and it's what led her
to kill so many people
what i thought was interesting is that
niccolo chimed in saying that they all
have a devil inside them and in his case
this was shown when he was fully
prepared to kill gabby after realizing
what she did to sasha he finishes by
saying that to overcome the devils
inside them they need to at least keep
trying to leave the forest
this is a direct reference to where mr
brown said the world is a giant forest
where everyone's fighting for their
lives and that the young people need to
leave this forest to end the cycle of
killing
back at the fort one of the main cadets
was about to be eaten by a pure titan
and if this time looks familiar it's
because he was the drunk mp from episode
10 who argued that they should turn
astoria into a titan even though she was
pregnant
instructor chardis then swoops in just
in time to save the cadets having
seemingly forgiven them for beating him
up not that long ago the instructor's
plan here was to use himself and the
recruits as bait and lure the titans to
the fort where their scouts could finish
them off
moments like this definitely make you
appreciate just how much the main cast
has evolved since they're now the
veterans that everyone's relying on in
times like this
when it comes to mikasa i guess you
could say she was always one of the
elite soldiers from the very beginning
but for everyone else it's interesting
just how quickly they all had to grow up
this shot of them diving off the roof
was easily one of the best in the entire
episode and as they deal with the swarm
of titans armin is the one who steps up
to deliver the finishing blow on pixis
all of his leadership and achievements
are why he was the first person john
thought of when evaluating who to feed
falco to but with the warrior candidate
missing there wasn't really any option
but to kill pixis there and then the
anime then shows us a brief shot of
mikasa's biggest fan watching her in
battle but while luis is distracted she
gets caught up in this explosion and
this will have serious consequences for
the character
sometime afterwards inside the fort
onyankapon realizes that his homeland is
going to be trampled by the rumbling
which is especially tragic considering
that his knowledge and skills were a
huge factor in why zeke and erin were
brought together he helped the people of
the island because he believed that this
was the best way to get revenge on
marley but instead it's now backfired in
the worst way possible
off to the side yelena seems to have
lost the will to live even more than he
has since zeke's euthanization plan
looks like it's not going to happen
an injured flock then arrives to arrest
the volunteers and if you're wondering
why he's in bad shape it's because he
was literally hanging onto the walls as
they began to come down
as the default leader of the yagaris
flock always made it very clear that
what he wanted was the rumbling and the
reason he wanted it was so that aliens
could guarantee their right to live
there's no way someone like him would
have ever supported the euthanization
plan and because yelena did support it
she's now under arrest he orders her to
round up the other volunteers as well
and this is so that he can determine
which of them have to die and which of
them are willing to serve in the new
alien empire
the final scene of the episode is mr
brass leading armin amika said to meet
gabby where she desperately pleased to
get falco back an interesting point she
raises is whether aaron could turn
connie's mother back into a human
without the need for her to eat a titan
shifter in theory this should be within
aaron's powers given that he has full
control over the dna of every eldian but
with him marching forward like i said
something like this isn't really a
priority
gabby then goes on to reveal that rhino
lost his hardening at the same time the
walls came down leading armin to realize
that all titan hardening has come undone
underground we get a good look at annie
coughing and spluttering now that her
crystal has been thought out and the
name of this episode was a reference to
this event ever since she was captured
her father maintained that she was alive
and that she would come back so it's no
coincidence that the new content in this
episode began with him and now it ends
with her
one final thing to say is that her
clothes are dripping wet almost like
she's been freed from ice which is
different to how other hardening was
shown to work therefore we can speculate
that the inside of this crystal might
have a slightly different makeup to
regular hardening and whatever it's made
of it likely stops her from physically
aging after all everything about her
looks exactly the same as when she was
captured whereas the other titan
shifters have visibly grown in that time
let me know your thoughts on this down
below and in general about the whole
episode and if this video helped your
understanding in any way then i'd
appreciate if you hit that sub button
and dropped a like thanks for watching
as always and until the next one peace
out